[Laughter]
hey welcome back to my channel and this
week
you have the most amazing guest on the
show
i say guest well amanda my wife has been
begging me for
weeks to come on the channel i haven't i
haven't and i finally caved in under the
pressure and said you know what
if you're that desperate to come on and
speak to my audience then then come on
so
you're right okay hey audience i have
not been begging
him to come on this channel you're
always trying to get me on your channel
okay okay the truth is amanda
mrs leeds is kind of the brains behind
the operation
okay a little bit a little bit and i
just think
it's right and fair not only for amanda
but also for you
to be able to hear where all the wisdom
comes from
wow big intro but you know i'll take it
now now not only are you really involved
in the property business but also
we are now officially a family of five
we are family of five we've got two
girls and one boy
welcomed our baby girl jessica and she
was born in february so you see like
six weeks ago yeah six weeks ago which
now means you can officially drive
yes i've been healing we had a plan
c-section so
recovery has been a little bit tough
this time but
here i am that's your third c-section
first one
was dreadful first of all the second one
was planned which is amazing third one
was planned
are you gonna are you gonna want any
more or are you done i don't know
at the moment i'm open i'm open i'm not
totally closed off so considering
six weeks later yeah when you're still
recovering you're saying i'm open that
means there's probably going to be a
yeah
i'm i'm easy man like my attitude is
um you probably have i was gonna say
suffer more but that's not the right
word you probably
go through a lot more go through a lot
more yeah so i wouldn't be like
oh we need to have another one right
yeah i won't push for it
before we got married we were both like
we want kids yeah
i didn't want to have just one kid two i
would have been happy
i'm happy with two happy three i'm
having four yeah well with two you were
like oh
if you didn't want to have any more i
think we'd be happy and i was just
especially with a boy and a girl yeah
talk to me about what you've been up to
so
pregnant then had the baby um as samuel
mentioned we went in for
a plan c section which was um it's
always good because i feel like
pregnancy when the birth is always
unknown but when you're having a plan
c-section then you know the date
you know when to prepare for it's just
it means you can do things like
financial freedom challenges just before
yeah yeah yeah you were away cutting it
really really it is
it is fine and you were literally having
contractions and stuff so it was a bit
crazy but
it worked out it worked out fine um so
what does life look like for mrs leeds
right now you've got three kids
right you're working on the property
business you're now back driving
yes so what are you doing what is a
typical day of life for you a typical
day
is up with jessica um
feeding her first thing and then she
usually goes to sleep
and then i'll then um either give her a
bath
or take her downstairs this is very
interesting for you
take a day in the life take it out take
it downstairs it's the only time you'll
get me to listen to your name yeah
yeah cause samuel always complains that
when he asks me a question i go into so
much detail but
i can't help it next i'll tell you what
i have for breakfast yeah
i usually yeah i usually don't really
have breakfast but anyway
um make your porridge if you're around
the daily porridge
daily porridge in this daily spot very
predictable
every day if you're her anyway yeah go
downstairs
start hanging out with um ruby and luke
as well and then we usually just either
if the weather's nice we'll go to the
park or we'll be inside
pain just do stuff with the kids
basically we are in constant
communication we're always doing stuff
yeah
even if it's if it's social if it's on
the business um
even when jessica was born you know not
only was i there
but i felt like i was really involved
we kind of were i even you were moral
support i even
i asked if i could cut the umbilical
cord oh yeah and they said
you can't you can cut it but only after
it's been cut
yeah yeah it's like yeah just to make
sure you're gonna damage anything
but what's the point in cutting the
umbilical cord
after it's been like if they cut it and
you and jessica are now
separated what's the point but then i
come and cut it as well
it's like when you humor a kid ah let
them have a go
so so i was thinking like oh man great
however
it was traumatizing just cutting the
umbilical cord i'm glad that it was just
a second
pointless cut and it had been the main
one you would have really it was really
you still haven't shown me the footage
of that no i haven't been so they
recorded him doing it because i
i pushed you i was like oh just do it
just do it you weren't really up for it
and i was like oh but you know it's just
the moment that dads have with the baby
like
the first moment but you still haven't
shown me actually i haven't shown you
and i always forget to ask you i haven't
shown you the footage the reason is
is because i swear i cut it
and blood comes out and as i cut it she
starts crying and i thought that it must
have happened
crying and i was like oh bleep
and it wasn't particularly it wasn't
like a sentimental moment so that's why
i've not bothered showing you
okay as well so that was her first
memory of you
well yeah yeah not quite but okay so you
had the baby we've now got three kids
yes um we are you are a quantity
surveyor
in property we run the samuel leeds
foundation together that's kind of what
i wanted to talk about because i think
that
in this in this video i want to talk a
little bit about what the charity is um
uh sunderland's foundation how it works
how it came into existence yeah
so talk to me y'all okay so
i'm born and bred in zimbabwe a lot of
people always ask me where i'm from i'm
zimbabwean
and um i've always like had the heart to
want to help people that are less
fortunate
or in less fortunate positions so um
that's something that i always wanted
why did you go to england we came to
england because my parents could see
that the economy was just like on its
way down
yeah and they wanted us to have the best
opportunities if they'd have sent us out
of zimbabwe to university
probably would have been quite expensive
doing it that way so they thought
if they could move with all of us as a
family as opposed to
them staying there and us being sent
away for school for whatever reason okay
so you guys came into work okay i'm glad
you did because we wouldn't have met i
know
i know yeah i ended up in leeds and now
my last name's leeds
there we go there we have it okay so you
came to zimbabwe and you always wanted
to
came to the uk sorry i came to the uk
from zimbabwe
meanwhile everybody knows my story
teenager
18 years old spent a month in zimbabwe i
actually went to sorry in zambia i went
to the border of zimbabwe
but i was too scared to go in because i
heard really bad things about the
zimbabwe
no so i went to the border i saw
victoria falls
not from the greatest side seeing it
from the zoom side
yeah it's debatable so i've spent a
month in zambia
um and and same same story same as you
really saw
a lot of people that were in need and i
just sort of vowed if i become really
successful
i am going to you know help some of the
villagers that i went to
started those those works when i was in
my early 20s
then we met when i was 22.
you 22. i think i was 22. yeah you were
22. i was 21.
yeah but yeah so you were 21 i was 22.
we got together and then we
took our first trip out to zambia yes
in together 2014 2015 2015.
six years ago yeah um but i was glad
that i met
someone who had the same passion that i
did
to help people that were in need so it
was and the fact that you'd been
to africa and travelled lots of
different countries more well-traveled
in africa than i was and i would be
african yeah i've i've already watched
it you're the african yeah and now oh
okay
okay okay he's laughing because every
time he
refers to me as african i'm like i'm
zimbabwean because africa is a big
continent like
egypt's and africa hold on you just
referred to yourself as africa yeah only
to stress the point that i was making
in that in that sentence in that context
what's wrong with africa there's nothing
wrong with being african
but but she corrects me and then she
calls me european yeah because then i
say you're a european then if i'm
african because africa is big
okay i'm not saying i'm just saying
you're african-american i'm african and
zimbabwe yeah yeah okay so yeah so
anyway he was well traveled in africa
than i was and i'm from zimbabwe i'm
afraid what did we do on our first trip
we did some baubles so we went to some
villages
in um they were quite isolated weren't
they in seoul wesley
uh so we have to fly into zambia and
then
when you're in what's the capital
they're from lusaka
you can take a little plane or have like
a seven
ten hour uh road trip like 16 hours yeah
it's like so long to drive to this part
of um
zambia which is really really isolated i
don't think we've ever flown no we've
flown
once yeah we flew once yeah but yeah
yeah
especially as we've got like teams with
us and you know and also the planes to
be fair they're so tiny they're looking
i know it's
cool yeah oh i was quite scared but yeah
so yeah first first one together he went
and did some waterfall hauls
many times though we've been to africa
on a trip a mission trip
to whether it be to bring clean water or
food or whatever it is
you are usually pregnant and then have
to cancer at the last minute
i know i know i am glad
honestly god was really looking out for
me do you remember when i was pregnant
we were literally you were flying the
next day we were going together to
uganda yeah
and then the day before the day before i
realized like
i can't actually like i don't know what
i think it was on it was the zika virus
yeah
and they were saying as a pregnant
person you really shouldn't be going so
we thought about it we prayed about it
and we came to the conclusion that
you're probably better from adam's step
you were gutted i was so good and that
was the day before you were going i was
like oh
yeah cause i hadn't been to uganda but
you'd been but then as it happened i
spent the entire time in uganda
lying in a hospital bed with a broken
leg yeah so it's probably for the best
i know that you weren't there because if
you'd have been there that would mean
you know i mean
i might have been on the bus you never
had to spend the whole time looking
after me i mean imagine
i look after you all the time yeah but
you could have yeah it could have been
bad
yeah you were on the boat yeah um and
then we last
last we were in uganda um and and we
were in negotiations we just negotiated
to partner with the ugandan government
to build a school
but then that was just before the
pandemic yes the pandemics
like slow down a lot of stuff annoying
but we've got big plans
and i can't wait to go i just can't
believe how long it's been
yeah we go every year and also it's uh
you registered well not it was actually
gary spicer from church and some people
that helped us with it
but we now have officially i'm actually
like it just happened
and then it happened like 2019 yeah but
still
it was just before the pandemic and time
was still still a little bit in terms of
the works that we've been doing
um but now registered samuel's
foundation so it's all registered
yeah um all right common questions that
we get asked because in fact if you've
got questions for amanda or
for me and amanda comment below we
should do this again
yeah yeah yeah we should do it every
week by the way wow wow
wow you know the start where i said
amanda's been begging me to come on the
channel and you laugh and say it's not
true
you can see it first time first hand
do you want to see every week i mean do
you really want to say
amanda every single week talking about i
guess yeah you do bring a lot of
property value i don't probably talk
property today yeah but
you well actually we'll go through the
questions that we get asked
what do you do in the business what's
your property qualifications and
background
okay so my qualifications uh quantity
surveyor that's what i studied and
that's
what i worked as throughout uni and
after
yeah so that's my qualifications so
you're you're a quantity surveyor what
does it
what does one of those do a quantity
surveyor is basically the person that
manages all the costs
in the construction process so from
whenever someone has an idea and says oh
this is what i want to build
the architect will draw the drawings and
then we'll be given the drawings as a
quantity surveyor
and then we'll do the costs and see how
much it's going to cost so
it starts from like a feasibility report
to see like how much it's going to cost
up until like the end of the project um
closing the account
so from what we do now yeah in our
property business
how does that help with what we do well
in the development side of stuff
especially it helps but just generally
it helps because for example when you're
dealing with builders getting quotes
being able to sense check and think like
oh this sounds reasonable for
what they're saying or cost management
yeah just kind of having an idea on
costs
and you've done you've worked with big
clients like coca-cola yeah massive
massive renovations okay so that's your
background yeah what are the most common
questions that you
get asked about i mean one of the
questions i get some of the time is
happening
oh yeah that's a big one which was at a
wedding yeah people always think that we
met
through business or i don't know we met
at a wedding in fact i didn't even tell
amanda about my i was in property when
we met no you didn't
even though at the time i had a large
property portfolio
um i didn't tell amanda no you didn't
you didn't and he was just finished
he just finished bible college um and i
just thought i'd be a pastor's wife
honestly you thought you're going to be
married to a pastor yeah yeah
here's what happened i built my
portfolio and then when i was 20
20 21 that kind of age i went to bible
college for a few years
and i met amanda i think i was just in
my last year of bible college yeah well
you were just finishing live finally
yeah
just finished during their bouts so i
must have been 20 then yeah i was up
age 20 21 22. so when i met you i was 22
yeah yeah right
so just i just finished i was just
finishing bible college and
my property portfolio was all systemized
and managed and i'm thinking i don't
know exactly what i'm going to do next
you know i've got my portfolio i'm
setting up my charity i just finished
college
i just launched training kings which was
a christian business training
company for to help people in business
uh of faith
and i met amanda and i was looking a
little bit not a crossroads but
kind of a crossroads in my life and i
just thought you know what rather than
saying to her
oh i've got this property portfolio
stuff yeah i was like nah
i'm just going to tell her i've just
finished bible college i'm setting up a
charity
i'll just keep the property business
separate
um because i didn't want amanda at the
time i didn't know you obviously know
you now know that you wouldn't even
think like this but i didn't want you to
be attracted to
me because of my property portfolio i
just wanted to get to know you
as you and me as me um and then
you know i told you maybe two or three
months after once we got to know each
other yeah yeah and then we were married
within nine months
yeah so we met our wedding um
one of the common questions i get asked
is
people sometimes neighbors sometimes
think
that i'm with a different woman on
different days
i'm really not okay we have a mum what's
it called
mom i don't know what the word is but
monogamous monogamous
relationship right however you do look
very different depending on what day of
the week you catch yeah because i change
my hair
all the time so yeah different wigs and
stuff so you'll probably see a different
look or you probably have seen different
looks if you've watched
this and people can't get over it you
know because your wigs look so
real i mean yeah anyway what's the most
common question you've asked so i get
asked
what's it like being married to samuel
because he's high energy
all the time yeah and i think people
always just think like oh when he gets
home does he just come and crash and
then what's he like at home but
i always say you're just the same so
always high energy
unless you're sleeping you just kind of
like go go go
but it's not a bad thing neither i i
love it a little a little top thing
about mine amanda that
people probably don't know is we have
never ever
had a fallout no we haven't ever
we've never had like a heated argument
ever we've got disagreements and
discussions but
we've never fallen out we've never been
around um
which is crazy and i remember what
people used to say because i remember
we're going out with you six months
going out we've been going out six
months we were about to get married
and i used to tell some of my friends
we've never had an argument and then
oh without changing you get married yeah
and then we got married no never never
never by the way defining argument an
argument would not be
what why do you think that's the best
thing to do no i think it's good
okay all right okay let's do this that's
not an argument
that's a discussion an argument is
heated
you know you're
like you know we've had once or twice
like a bit of a tiff i'm trying to think
of it
on uh when we when we went to see jason
manford
oh yeah yeah yeah but it was hard yeah
it wasn't even that deep and to be fair
it was me what happened
so samuel got gifted tickets to go see
jason manford
we were going to be away that weekend as
well in the peak district
on like a little get-together with my
cousins so
it fell on one of the nights that we're
going to be away and
i got asked by the person who's given us
the tickets
russell he rang me and he said i've got
um samuel lee's tickets
is it okay um did you say i've got
samuel lee's ticket
no i said i've got samuel some tickets
i've got some of these tickets for
myself just again you'll need some
tickets no no no no no russell
anyway russell rang me to ask for
permission to say
is it okay if you know you can take
samuel these are the tickets that we got
in and i was just like yeah yeah that's
fine
but really i just kind of thought oh
great
yeah but so it was it was my fault from
the get-go because i didn't just say to
him but then you were just a little bit
like oh about it and then on the day
you were like oh i was just basically
dragging my feet
yeah i was like all right let's go and
you're like oh so
i was like come on man we need to go
yeah yeah and then we left and you were
just like oh
great and you weren't you just did a
little bit of a bit of a mood about it
yeah kind of like dragging all great
yeah which you've never ever done before
anything yeah no i didn't have an
argument and i just just sort of said
hey come on yeah you're like is there a
problem here like what's happening you
don't seem
if you're not happy just say i don't
want to go and then we can have a
conversation don't go and pull a face
like what's up
and then you were just like fair enough
my bad and then that was it and we were
just fine
that's the only time ever yeah yeah
it's very mild so what is the secret
to i mean we're married now what six
years
six six years we've got three kids
married six years
what is the secret to uh a happy
relationship
i would say the secret is putting each
other first
so always considering the other person's
feelings
sometimes when people i feel like when
people argue it's because one person's
trying to
i don't know be the one so if you came
to me upset about something that i did
then i could exasperate you by then i
don't know
having to go at you for having to go at
me or whatever and then it just goes
back and forth
but even in the moment if you think that
the other person's wrong you can just
help by just being nice to them and kind
to them in that moment
and then once they're not so emotional
or you know
then just having the conversation yeah
like yeah i think
that's one of the things that we do like
let's say i
am annoyed about something maybe i'm
being unreasonable and i'm like oh what
the heck man what
and i'm just a bit annoyed you will let
me be annoyed
yeah without going why are you annoyed
but yeah he's like all right
timmy happened cool be annoyed for a
minute and then usually i'll then
let it out what the heck man why is this
person doing this might be a little bit
around mandy will be nice
and rather having a go at me we'll just
go okay maybe a cup of tea or whatever
and then within two minutes i'll think i
was probably a little bit
you're really good samuel's so good at
you always say when you're wrong or and
apologize that even if
even if i didn't even think anything and
you you're always like oh i'm sorry if i
was a bit snappy earlier but the thing
is it's easy to do that
because you let me be annoyed so if i'm
like
let's say something happens right i
can't think you've already been an
example because i don't get annoyed a
lot yeah
you don't get annoyed a lot yeah let's
say i did get annoyed right and i'm like
oh what the heck this person did this
and this
oh and i'm annoyed and maybe i'll just
be a bit short with you
yeah and if you then were like well hang
on a minute and had a go at man
it would probably human nature met me
more and then it's like fire with fire
whereas because you're sweet about it
it's the only natural reaction for me as
a human
is then to just think ah oh you know
what i was probably about
hey i'm sorry if i was a bit short sweet
even if you get busy or whatever
i always know that i'm always number one
priority yeah always
and even with business like i
i think family ultimately comes first
yeah so although
business has to come first or sometimes
say business first
i'll say that but when it really comes
to it i think family comes first yeah
i'll give you an example
if it was like oh um oh my
sister's got a birthday party and i'm
like well i'm doing the deal
right i'll skip the parties in the book
i'll skip it
but if it was something really important
like if you weren't well you know i'll
be straight
home yeah so it's kind of like you know
i think ultimately family comes first
but you do have to make sacrifices in
business
i make a lot of sacrifices you know and
and when we met although i had a big
property portfolio
already like that's great but
i was nowhere near the level
of wealth and success i'm at now i
didn't become a millionaire until i was
25 which was after
i met you you know yeah but to get to
a high level of success in business i do
think you have to make sacrifices and i
also think my philosophy is
and i teach this and everyone goes oh
yeah i like that oh yeah it makes sense
where i teach
if you're not learning and you're not
earning and you're not having fun you
shouldn't do it
i'll teach that right i'll say you know
if you're not earning
or learning or having fun don't do it
everyone goes oh yeah i agree
but most people don't actually live by
that i actually
live by that yes he does actually if i'm
not making
money or learning from the experience
or having fun guess what i ain't doing
it yeah i'm not doing it if i'm not
topping up tires
in my car and messing up i'm just like
no i never make amanda do it
no you can't say you have to do it
amanda i'll say i ain't doing it
someone has to do it it's not me
sometimes you might do it but if you
don't want to do you pay somebody to do
it i don't care
but i'm not doing it that's kind of how
i live i i outsource my we outsource
outsourcing yeah we outsource our lives
so all right cool and everyone asks you
always like being married to me and
you've kind of been shared a little bit
kind of shared on that what other
questions well i want to say what's like
married to you oh
you meant to amanda oh wow amazing
honestly you're just an incredible wife
great great business lady interior
designer
oh my goodness are you qualified at
interior design
i did a course on interior and do you do
interior design and approaches
yes so are you an interior designer it
always calls me an interior designer
yes i guess i am i guess i am
technically you don't think you are
because really you're qs
yeah i just don't feel like yeah you're
an amateur you're an amateur i'm an
amateur
but you still do a good job but also you
know a great friend
and um i'm glad to have you on on our
podcast
do you want to see this regular do you
want to see amanda back do you think
they should say yes
uh yes say yes and if you say yes as
well
just click the like button there we go
and drop a comment for amanda or me in
the in the comments and then next time
we'll answer
your questions subscribe peace out